High speed Internet, supersonic
jets, instant coffee,
and some noodles. Would you
believe our world is slowing down?
They say time flies when you're having
fun. But over the past 100 years,
including the twenties the sixties and
the eighties or days have actually gotten
longer before you say you're telling me,
let's just clarify,
the average length of a day has
only increased by 1.7 milliseconds.
But what if you could get more out
of your day? What if a great night,
never had to add?
What if one day lasted an entire year?
And in that time you could walk around
the whole earth. This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the
earth were to suddenly stop spinning.
The earth rotates at an average speed of
1000 miles per hour giving us night and
day while harnessing wind,
tides and temperature.
So what would happen if these revolutions
that are so vital to our existence
were to suddenly stop?
Okay.
Imagine owning the fastest, sexiest
sports car in the world. Pretty Nice, Huh?
The open road calls,
there's no traffic and sight and
no highway patrol officers either.
So you decide to test its top speed
driving at 1000 miles per hour out of
nowhere an obstacle, you hit the brakes,
your car stops suddenly, but you don't.
That's what would happen at the moment.
The earth stops spinning.
Everything that isn't safely secure or
tied down will be suddenly sent flying
eastward at 1000 miles
per hour. Humans, cars,
even pigs.
The fastest wind ever recorded
was 253 miles per hour.
In this scenario, we're talking
about wins four times as strong,
feeling similar to an atomic
blast in less than a minute,
towering tsunamis would sweep
more than 17 miles inland,
all the water from the world's
oceans with surge towards the Poles.
Since the globe bulges at the equator,
the north and South Pole are closer to
the center of the earth and therefore
have a stronger gravitational pull.
The seven seas would turn into two
forming one mega ocean in the north and
another in the South Canada.
Most of Europe and Russia would be
completely submerged. Boston, Chicago,
and Seattle would also be underwater
along with parts of Argentina, Chile,
and New Zealand.
The oceanic displacement would form a
massive supercontinent along the equator
wrapping around the entire earth.
While this might make it easier for
any surviving humans to work together,
there'd be little anyone
could do to improve their lot.
Resources would be scarce. The world
would experience widescale drought,
and most species would be
endangered if not already extinct.
Agriculture would be nearly impossible
to maintain since a full day would now
last an entire year.
In other words,
you'd see the sun for six straight and
spend the other half of the year in
darkness. This would also inhibit the
natural transition between seasons.
The final fatal consequence would
be the loss of our magnetic field.
Aside from giving us a sense of direction,
Earth's magnetic field ensures our
survival by deflecting solar wind,
which would otherwise rip through our
ozone layer and blast us with harmful
radiation.
Deadly cosmic rays would effectively
kill all living things on the planet and
over time the world is, we know it
would turn into Mars as we know it.
Wait a minute. Are we trying to travel
to Mars and possibly live on it?
Our Mars and earth?
Just going to switch places.
If this what it means to come full circle.
Even if we don't come
to a screeching stop,
the world will one day stop spinning
in about 18.5 billion years.
So for now, enjoy the time you have,
seize the day and make every night great.